just a little bit about professor wargo
he's a professor of environmental risk
analysis and policy at yale school of
forestry and environmental studies he's
also a professor of political science
and the director of the environmental
excuse me the environment and health
initiative his recent work is on is
focusing on children's exposure to air
pollution especially diesel emissions
uh he received his degrees from the
university of pennsylvania and he's an
alum of yale he's gotten his master's
and also his doctorate from yale
university
um i don't know about you but i'm very
excited about learning about the impact
of the environment on our life so with
with would you please welcome me excuse
me welcome john together with me to the
podium
thank you very much
thank you dr ramirez and there's a brief
uh ceremony that we'll engage in now as
a gift for you hi everybody i'm tom
d'andrea from the children's center and
i i'm here to thank dr anisa ramirez for
her wonderful efforts at promoting the
uh
the importance of science to young
children
um
my students were very impressed by your
contributions dr ramirez uh they really
admire you for your efforts and your
commitment to children yes there is the
world of sports yes there is the world
of boys and there is the world of
fashion but there's also the wonderful
world of ideas and science and discovery
and you've made a great contribution to
that and my girls really want to thank
you my boys want to thank you and kayla
who's our superstar she has a little
something but thank you very much
okay well i'll start in thank you all
for coming out on a saturday morning
and i thought that what i would do would
be to share with you the types of
research questions that i am interested
in
and also to give you my sense of
what's worth worrying about with respect
to the environment and human health
it's a complicated issue and and uh
every day in the new york times or
whatever uh media you uh you uh
look at you you find competing claims of
of uh uh what's worth worrying about
uh so i'm selecting several cases uh
that i've worked on during my career
and these involve land
food
water and air
and the threats that are associated with
especially contaminants in those
different environmental media
so
my machine
was locking up there
i wanted to start by
giving you my idea that environmental
law
has become very complicated
during the past three or four decades
and since 1960 we have
more than three dozen federal statutes
and many mirror images of those statutes
at the state governmental level i'm not
going to talk about all these laws
but i want to raise the question in your
mind whether or not these laws have been
effective in making
environmental quality higher or better
and i'll be talking about several of
these laws especially the safe drinking
water act
the superfund law that is designed to
control
the cleanup of hazardous facilities
also the federal insecticide statute
the food drug and cosmetic act
so i'm going to concentrate on four
cases that deal with land
with with water
with food and then with air and my
research also is focused on the special
risks faced by kids
and pregnant women
and the
reason for that is that children are
often
much more vulnerable to a variety of
environmental contaminants than adults
are and by the way the the definition of
a child uh
in
in the pediatric world now uh it ends at
the age 21
and there's some evidence that
the full development of neural
architecture
doesn't conclude for some until the
early 20s
so during periods of rapid growth and
development of organ systems
and cells
these may be periods of time when
people
our youngest are most susceptible to
some damage
kids also
behave differently than adults do or or
the elderly and their patterns of
behavior cause them to be exposed to
chemicals in very different ways
so that a toddler for example crawling
on the floor
a toddler picking up things from the
floor so that their hand and mouth
behavior can transfer chemicals
that make their way down to the floor or
deliberately applied to the floor such
as indoor application of pesticides
so that the pattern of exposure is not
uniform across the population
so i'm really interested in these these
problems where
the
contamination or the exposure is is not
uniform that it's quite variable and
then in my research i wonder whether or
not law has the capacity to
direct government to identify this
distributional pattern i think about it
as pockets of high risk out there or
high contamination that could be defined
by the location of pollution but also
could be defined by this issue of
variable susceptibility that i just
mentioned
susceptibility isn't just
a term to describe children but it could
describe the elderly it could describe
certain people
that are genetically
more prone to illness
or
they may be defined
by their inability to cope with these
problems in other words
the wealthiest are in many ways
the most capable of managing risky
situations through insurance or access
to good health care
so if you think about where these
problems are worst in the world or in
the united states
i think it's important to think about
the kind of of ways that
different groups have to to manage risk
and to manage health
there's a whole body of law as well to
deal with management of land especially
federal land and i won't be talking
about that other than to say
that the whole area of environmental
health as it's evolved in our legal
system has
really been quite uh distinct uh from
the management of land uh and i'm
curious about that because i think that
the the the way we manage land has
terrific implications for how we're
exposed to chemicals in our environment
uh and the way that we we
uh control land use in particular uh the
location of different facilities such as
uh
water supply lines or transportation
networks these have terrific
implications for future growth patterns
as well as patterns of contamination
associated with with
higher density populations
i'll mention uh several other statutes
just at the beginning here because i
think these laws are
extremely important to
managing environmental quality and
managing human health but most people
don't think about it like that these are
statutes that have evolved to control
ownership of information
who owns knowledge of risk who's got the
who has the right to keep information
secret well the government does under
certain circumstances uh so that uh you
know our our
more current concerns about homeland
security and managing terrorist threats
is believed to justify government
classifying some information as as
secret
but there's also
patent law
governing trade secrecy
that allows the private sector to
not disclose certain ingredients in
foods or in other products
one example of that would be artificial
ingredients
so artificial
flavors as an example they're not
required to be listed on food products
and you have no right to to get access
to those ingredients i have a daughter
who has a very severe allergic reaction
to an artificial grape flavor
and as an example of that we have a
really hard time in our family trying to
figure out what foods might have that
flavor in it and the law that protects
the full disclosure of these ingredients
can be a problem so when you think about
environmental law you might think about
the the traditional pollution statutes
but keep in mind the land and resource
management statutes and then this third
body of law which i think is very
important that governs your right to get
access to information so what's your
right to know well it's actually pretty
complicated
and it allows a lot of decisions to be
made about environmental
management that
do not demand full disclosure
i'm going to jump across a couple of
sites here or slides here so that i can
move ahead and
share these cases with you
i'll give you one example of of the land
management problem that we face and my
perception of the scale of the problem
we have a law called the the superfund
law that was designed to identify and
clean up uh severely contaminated sites
in in the nation and right now there are
about 1200 different sites that are are
listed on this national priority list
and the rate of cleanup is uh what i
think of as as moving at a glacial pace
uh so about 300 of those sites have been
cleaned up
now recently the federal government
published a report that estimated that
the defense department and the interior
department alone
are responsible for managing 40 000
severely contaminated sites so most
military bases most energy facilities
nuclear power plants
the
the former atomic weapons testing areas
these are all
severely contaminated sites and this
government report that came out just a
few weeks ago estimated that the cost of
cleanup of those contaminated sites
is now approaching one half trillion
dollars uh the superfund law
was funded by
congress and attacks on certain
industries uh and congress has allowed
that tax to expire uh now the super fund
uh uh is actually uh empty there there
is no funding uh other than funding
that's allocated specifically by
congress uh to federal agencies to go
out and clean up these messes so i'm
gonna give you one example of this
problem uh on a site that i've been
working on for the past three or four
years down in puerto rico this is a
former military base the roosevelt roads
naval air station uh off the east end of
puerto rico uh va case island a little
island it's one of the spanish virgin
islands here about 23 miles long and
about 5 miles wide and in 1940 or
41 following the bombing of pearl harbor
the the government decided that they
better not concentrate their naval fleet
in one area
so they were looking for bases in other
parts of the world and they chose uh the
east end of puerto rico as as a good
site
because it would give them access to the
south atlantic as well as
provide a safe harbor for the british
fleet which was experiencing increasing
uh
pressure from the germans so this became
the largest military base uh in the
atlantic
and it also became a center for storage
of weapons
some 250 different types of weapons had
been stored there and these have
included atomic weapons and uh
2000 pound bombs
and the the population that lived in the
area was
was moved out of the area and
dislocated
to the center part of the island you can
see that somewhat
by the development in the core center
area on the north
and then the eastern part of the island
was heavily bombed so that
intense military activities occurred
there and this raised this raises a very
interesting problem just several months
ago it was declared by the governor of
puerto rico to be a superfund site every
every governor has the capacity to
identify one site in their state to
become a superfund site that does not
have to go through epa's purview
so it is now a superfund site so i got
involved in this uh
predominantly because
people mentioned to me that the children
on the island were experiencing a high
level of certain adverse health effects
asthma hypertension
and a higher incidence of certain forms
of cancer including neuroblastoma
so the question uh that i'm facing now
is well is the navy in any way
associated with exposures that might
have led to these kinds of health
outcomes it turns out to be a very
complicated issue
one of the key questions is well what
did the navy dump on the island
going back and piecing together material
over time i found that uh about 150
million pounds of bombs or other uh
weapons had been dropped on this island
since 1945
and
the damage to the island has also
included disruption of coastal
ecosystems cutting down mangrove lagoons
uh plowing down sand dunes and and
allowing seawater to to wash in
and also to disrupt certain endangered
and threatened species sites for
manatees pelicans and uh three different
species of endangered sea turtles that
nest right on the beach and here's an
example of a naval maneuver
and uh
the navy would often bring uh
30 or 40 ships and this became a center
for
for nato operations and training
exercises and uh up until night uh 2003
uh very intense operations were staged
here so that before uh uh
the navy would uh
go to vietnam or to the uh first gulf
war
or even the iraq war the training for it
was commonly centered right here
one example of uh a problem that uh
remains is the uss killen and uh
uh i've been writing about uh
radioactive waste and uh its
mismanagement and uh just happened to
stumble across the the fact that the
killing
killin
was used as a target ship for
naval bombing so planes would fly over
the ship
off of puerto rico it turns out it has a
kind of a long and interesting history
it was part of the atmospheric atomic
weapons testing program in the marshall
islands uh during the mid 1950s and
here's actually a shot of
operation hard attack that include two
different blasts so that that ship the
the killen had an atomic weapon exploded
beneath it and one above it and became
radioactive
and because
the navy didn't really know what to do
with these radioactive hulks that didn't
sink
they started dispersing them some went
to california and uh some remain in san
diego and san francisco in shipyards but
one was dragged through the panama canal
and off the east end of puerto rico and
then used for training practices until
uh the mid 1990s when it was when it was
sunk and now the
uh nobody's really certain what the
level of contamination is that it's
giving off uh but it has a variety of
different problems associated with it
including fuels and other toxic
substances that that most of these
of these ships contain
uh but it also is interesting in that uh
about six months ago i was diving uh
over over the site uh
where this this ship is lying on the
bottom and and uh it has barrels of
unknown substances that are leaking
it has a variety of weapons
bombs that are as long as this table
lying next to it that didn't explode
and when the navy flyers flew over the
island and dropped their bombs
approximately 50 percent of them didn't
hit their target uh they were either too
short or too far
which means that the ocean is littered
with this uh uh storage of unexploded
ordnance uh that's now rusting out
leaking into the environment because
fish are the predominant source of
protein for many of the islanders uh one
of the interesting questions is could
those contaminants have moved into the
food chain
and into the fish and into the dinner
tables of the via kenzie population and
into their bodies
so you can see that it's setting up a
kind of a very interesting but a very
difficult scientific problem to
understand whether or not these naval
activities might have affected
uh the population and what the root of
exposure is there are three main routes
of exposure that one worries about in my
field one is inhalation another is
ingestion by food or water or i
mentioned earlier hand to mouth movement
and then the other is dermal uptake and
depending upon the chemical and
depending upon
its form and its formulation
you can get significant exposures to
chemicals
by all three of these roots cosmetics is
a good example of that you don't think
that cosmetics are going to get into
your bloodstream but many cosmetics are
detectable or compounds that are within
the cosmetics are detectable in human
tissues and and move through your your
bloodstream
because of rapid dermal transfer
so that the navy uh also was was
experimenting with biological and
chemical agents uh they weren't just
doing this by the way at va case they
were doing this uh in many different
parts
of the of the country in in the world uh
so that they would spray
fuels on the landscape they would ignite
those fuels and then they would try the
effectiveness or test the effectiveness
of a variety of different flame
retardants to put put out
the fires and many of these compounds
now are detectable and underlying
groundwater sources and they create an
enormously expensive
cleanup problem
so how do you how do you take a a cubic
meter of soil and how do you rid it of
of
say the
a flame retardant or benzene that comes
from fuel it's a very expensive process
and i'll talk about that in another case
in just a moment when you walk across
this island today
there are about 150 to 175 different
types of ordnance
some of these bombs exploded and others
did not uh when i go down to my research
site there are some areas that i can't
go into unless i have
navy seals accompany me that uh
tell me you know where i should hop hop
step across bombs and
and some are quite visible some are not
what what's in a bomb it's a pretty inc
a nasty mixture of chemicals some of
these you'll recognize as toxic
lead
mercury for example but also explosives
such as rdx
or
tnt
by the way the detection capacity for
these compounds now in mixtures that are
are commonly parts of weapons has gotten
extremely sensitive since 911
so that the airport technology when you
walk through the screening area and you
see them pull out their little cloth and
they wipe your your suitcase
then they put the cloth into a
device that that will give them a
reading quickly these are these are
capable of detecting some of these
compounds in the part per trillion level
so that that history of detection
sensitivity dropping is a very
interesting case so that many cases uh
in my field you find over time as this
detection sensitivity uh
improves and and you can find the
chemicals at lower and lower levels it
changes your image of of what's polluted
and what's not uh formally you would
have thought that an area was clean
because you weren't capable of detecting
it at a low enough level so you go back
into that environment with a sensitive
technology and you say my gosh this
stuff is actually moving uh in ways that
we just did not predicted in uh previous
time
who here knows what chaff is
not separating the wheat from the chaff
but what is dropped out of military
aircraft
during exercises like this in actual
combat missions these are thin strands
of fiberglass
that formerly had lead embedded within
them as well as aluminum and they're
designed to uh
basically
mask
military activities and maneuvers
because they they block radar
so the military was dumping uh this lead
and
aluminum and fiberglass
these groups of fibers
over over the island for uh decades by
the way they do it over other parts of
the nation as well
without warning people without telling
people to go inside
and without testing whether or not uh
significant amounts are actually
reaching the surface uh and then what
happens to it where does it where does
it go once it does reach the surface
uh this gives you a sense of what the
east end of the island looked like
several years ago
and you find these pock marked
holes uh when a bomb explodes
it basically uh uh
blows into billions of fragments
that get imploded into the side of a
crater
then these craters i think i might have
another shot here of then these craters
uh may fill up with water
and uh that uh that this is an
interesting part of the story because
what i've learned from this is that uh
these become toxic soups of of sort
and during periods of very high rain
tropical storms hurricanes you can get a
lot of water
over these over this island in a short
period of time last fall
tropical storm jean hung over the island
for 48 hours and dropped 23 inches of
rain in that period
i was down there the next week and saw
this entire area
turn into a lake overflow the mango
lagoons and drain into the adjacent
coastal waters
which are also favorite fishing grounds
for the villa kenzie
another example of
some of the problems some of the danger
here associated with
research in the area
it's getting worse too because nitrogen
is a significant compost component of
many bombs and nitrogen as you know is
also a fertilizer
so once the bombing stopped and these
plants stop getting blown to smithereens
the area has become lush with vegetation
and nobody has gone down there yet to
try to figure out whether or not
different species are absorbing the the
materials which materials at different
rates uh but uh the just the the
presence of the vegetation makes
visibility difficult and uh the entire
uh practice
uh more dangerous
uh one example of uh the bomb bomb some
of the bombs that we found beneath the
surface
wondering uh what their process of
degradation is and how they might be
leaking stuff into the environment and
then what might happen to it
by the way
uh here's here's an example
of the same site and that bomb runway
that i showed you and here you can see
the the lagoon
that if this were more refined it's it's
pock marked and this is the area where
the the lagoon is running off into uh
this bay bay uh del sur and uh this is
uh these are seagrass beds that happen
to be favorite habitat for some feces
species of fish that are very very much
uh loved by the via kenzie's including
conch
so conch stews a kind of a base for
their bouillabaisse
they're very common components of the
via kenzie's diet
as well as other other species such as
snapper the yellowtail snapper which is
blue with this yellow streak on it and
that are also heavily consumed by the
via kenzie so i'm interested in what was
dropped where and when where it might
have migrated how it might have moved
through the food chain
and into the fish markets or or into the
dinners of the population and then what
that might mean in terms of their health
effects so
a group of us are mounting a fairly
significant long-term project trying to
figure out fish contamination is a very
difficult thing and many of you have
probably heard about methylmercury and
fish and how you should be careful of
your tuna fish intake well you need to
be careful of a lot more than tuna fish
uh you need to be careful of of uh
any large uh predatory fish that sits
high in the food chain that has the
capacity to
build up chemicals that would include
mercury
include other metals include other
chlorinated
compounds such as pesticides or solvents
or pcbs so that the older the fish the
more contaminated it would be
but in terms of our study we're trying
to figure out
what chemicals might have gotten into
the fish that the via kenzie population
eat
so that because it costs us 200 to test
each individual fish to put this puzzle
together
and we need large sample sizes we have
to be very careful to know the habitat
of the fish whether or not they might
spend a good portion of their life cycle
in close proximity to the island
as a basis for selecting our our
sampling
so
uh just a piece of advice for you
give this to everybody that i talked to
about this project
my children don't eat tuna fish
because of the mercury content mercury
is especially bad for the developing
central nervous system
and most tuna fish have mercury
most swordfish has has mercury in it
so if you want to enjoy fish and you
want to to avoid these contaminants
i recommend eating very low on the food
chain
so eat young fish
small fish non-predatory fish
and
scallops and shrimp are good examples of
that
or squad when it was when it was
available
disease incidence on the island is very
uh
significantly elevated
above disease incidents on the main
island of puerto rico and also in
comparison to a
group of similarly aged
hispanic americans
so understanding the relationship
between these specific contaminants and
these specific illnesses is quite a
puzzle we are are not even close to
being able to make a claim about
the pattern of exposure that occurred
and whether or not uh there's
responsibility on the navy's part so
this is the kind of research that i've
tended to look at
to try to understand the magnitude of
contaminant released to the environment
uh where does a contaminant go once it's
released
how does it lead to a pattern of
exposure by inhalation ingestion or
dermal exposure
and what illnesses might be associated
with it
and in this case
it's pretty clear that it's going to
cost the navy a terrific amount of money
in order to clean this site up estimates
are in the range now of of four to eight
billion dollars
and again remember this is one of twenty
thousand different defense sites that
are hazardous facilities
uh the capacity of chemicals to move
long distances
from their point of release
is strong
studies of pesticides in california for
example have found that pesticides
applied with radioactive tracers have
sometimes been detected
in underground water supplies
four and five miles from their source
yes
doesn't that also affect the environment
well the half-life of the compounds are
extremely short that they would that
they would use and
the
government at least believes that the
the health risk from doing that is uh
negligible
and it's far more likely to provide
scientific insight in
how chemicals move into environments
that uh
where the chemical agent itself like the
active pesticide ingredient would be the
toxin of concern
same principle would apply to the use of
radioactive radioactive tracers
for for human health diagnosis
we've also begun tissue testing among uh
via kenzei and found that
many do have elevated levels of some of
the contaminants that you or some of the
compounds that you find in the bombs
so we're beginning to think about how
you could piece together an approach to
understand whether or not the mixture of
chemicals released by the navy uh might
also be found in the same
or within fish that are heavily consumed
by the via kenzie and uh then whether or
not uh uh the tissue samples themselves
might uh might contain a similar uh
group of chemicals yes for my student's
benefit to identify those metals oh sure
uh aluminum is on the top
aluminum is a very significant component
of most weapons lead is next
cadmium is next
mercury uh is hg and arsenic is a.s so
most of these are extremely known toxins
uh other than aluminum and uh
uh
they are the toxicology has been quite
well worked out and you certainly want
to avoid these if you can
we're also finding that individual
children often have elevated levels of
groups of these compounds so here's
another uh research strategy to think
about whether or not uh your population
has how many in your population has an
elevated level of
a toxic substance that's one question
this question is
how many how many children would have an
elevated level of more than one compound
so here you see that on the right hand
side over here
that
you've got cadmium lead arsenic and
aluminum that's elevated to about uh
above a reference range uh by the way
the reference range here is specific to
each individual chemical and you've got
about 10 percent of the population that
was sampled with these elevated levels
so this is enough uh evidence to to say
that it's worth additional research to
try to figure out uh whether or not
these compounds actually had their
origin in the in the naval activities
now i want to take you to cape cod
cape cod has the massachusetts military
reservation that has a very similar
history of having been a center for
training and and bombing activity
and you may not know it but this
military reservation was found to be
heavily contaminated and cape cod is is
a very interesting area
because
geologically it's basically a big sand
pile
and the sand pile has within it an
aquifer
and this is an aquifer that is quite
famous it's called a sole source aquifer
and gets a special degree of regulation
under environmental law
so that this entire
area on the
the cape is serviced by this one aquifer
it means it's all connected and it also
means that chemicals could flow easily
within this area now the massachusetts
military reservation was located right
here it's still active in fact that's
the the reservation
where the national guard jets were were
uh uh
flown to try to intercept the uh the
hijacked aircraft in 911
and the intensity of cleanup at this
site is really uh quite extraordinary
so i'd like you to think about this in
comparison to the va case story so that
in in
on the massachusetts military
reservation since 1993
3000 pounds of solvents have been
removed from this water supply a
thousand pounds of fuel that had been
dumped by the way in most
most military sites and at most airports
it's been very common for aircraft to
pull into one area and to
check the drain valves on their fuel
tanks simply by opening them up and
making sure that they leak in case they
had to dump fuel in an emergency
situation
so that they would reduce the potential
for an explosion if they had a crash
landing
so that there are sites that are heavily
contaminated by jet fuel which is a
pretty nasty mixture of toxic substances
so they're trying to figure out how to
get this jet fuel
out of the water supply and they've
mapped out these underground plumes they
have more than 5 000 wells that they had
to sink down into the the sandy area to
try to figure out uh the the movement of
of water as well as the contaminants
and also to continually monitor the
concentration of a variety of chemicals
including pesticides and solvents uh
degreasing agents used on aircraft
engines
in an attempt to try to to understand if
their pumping activity and their
filtration activity was making any any
progress
and this
this slide demonstrates that they are
making progress
so far
they have
expended close to
300 million dollars in their cleanup
efforts
they are pumping out
hundreds of millions of gallons of water
from the underlying aquifer
every month and pumping them through
these large carbon filters i was there
with my yale class
just two weeks ago showing them the site
and these filters are almost as high as
this auditorium is uh and the carbon
basically
attracts the contaminants they stick to
it
and then when they test the water at the
base of the tank and it exceeds a
certain
threshold they know that
the absorptive capacity is is uh
gone too low they have to get rid of the
carbon
so that they have warehouses filled with
these uh carbon tanks uh to pump uh
these billions of gallons per year of
water through it uh at this cost of 250
billion dollars
so that excuse me 250 million dollars uh
so one could think about this as an
environmental justice case i tend to
think of it like that uh in that you had
this very poor population in va case uh
that basically had a similar type of
military history associated with it they
have received no clean up dollars at all
and you have this other air base in
massachusetts
that has senator kennedy and a
kerry
that are very effective in getting funds
to the cape cod community
to clean it up as well as to provide
bottled water drinking water to
communities
that that formerly drank the water
coming out of this this area yes
the question is what do they do with the
the carbon once it's
been been contaminated
uh and the answer is they they recycle
it and i don't know what the process is
uh but there's a company that does the
recycling and then it can come back to
them uh what i don't know is where the
contaminants eventually end up and i
think that's a pretty good question
okay
so that that's land i'm going to scoot
through a couple of other cases quickly
here
and i just want to leave you with my
impression that our our intense
contamination of landscapes is going to
be haunting us
for probably hundreds of years and with
respect to land
even even if the government does nothing
trees vegetation will eventually come
back wildlife will come back into an
area
uh and unless you are an historian when
you go about the process of buying land
or or deciding where to live
you could uh you could make a very big
mistake in other words
when you are thinking about where to
live
uh where to work
i encourage you to think like an
historian
the majority of americans
now live within several miles of a
intensely contaminated site
yes
i just want to make this clear for my
students benefit so what you're saying
is spending hundreds of millions of
dollars to remove
chemicals from cape cod
but
you don't know
what ultimately happens to those
chemicals
is it possible
that well after all that money is spent
somebody is just dumping it somewhere
else
i think not and it's because of a
provision that we have in the the uh
superfund law that requires an
accounting of where those chemicals go i
don't know what happens to them
but i do not believe that they are
just dumped out in somebody else's
back 40.
yeah
okay now i want to switch gears a bit
and yes
uh yes you do
yes you do every town has a sanitary
landfill
and i think of that as being one of the
great oxymorons
that is in our language what's sanitary
about a landfill
not much and
you know before about 1990
lots of nasty stuff was dumped into
landfills around the world
around the country
before they were more heavily regulated
and many of these landfills are now
closed and i live in a town as an
example that uh where the the town's old
landfill
was transformed into a housing
development
and
parts of it were so contaminated that
they they transformed that into a land
trust because the town didn't really
want the land to be sold so they took it
over
and so now you you see a sign that says
land trust uh but if you look very
carefully take my students to the site
and
asked them to to tell me what the
history of the site was if you look
really carefully you can see these these
white pipes occasionally sticking out of
the field but otherwise it looks like
this beautiful
you know
trust land trust area wildlife deer
turkeys running through it
uh
and uh the drinking water and in the
that comes from the wells that were sunk
in the vicinity of it were found to be
contaminated by a variety of chemicals
that leached their way down through the
the water
i could tell you a lot about
connecticut's water i just finished a
project on connecticut's water supply
and
i'll just give you the short answer here
do not do not trust
well water have your well water tested
the safe drinking water act does not
cover
wells that serve fewer than 25 people or
16 households
and there are only
some 93 different uh chemical
contaminants on the safe drinking water
list that means the government is only
required to look for those 93 whereas
there are tens of thousands of hazardous
chemicals that are released to the
environment so there's a good example of
you know many people have the
expectation that we have this complex
body of law that is health protective uh
but if you're not even looking for a
variety of contaminants including most
pesticides that are not listed and not
not sought in these water supplies uh
then you can't uh you can't have a you
have a false sense of security is what
i'm suggesting yes
uh killingworth
killingworth yeah but i would i would
guess that many towns are the same by
the way
it's very common for
old hazardous waste sites to be
translated into
preserves of one sort or another and in
another
example of
congressional wisdom
the east end of vieques the most heavily
bombed out area was just turned over to
the u.s fish and wildlife service as a
wildlife refuge
as many hazardous military facilities
have also been and it also was declared
to be a federal wilderness area so that
pockmarked uh highly contaminated
landscape is uh as of two years ago now
part of our national federal wilderness
system uh the logic being well if we
call it wilderness then we can
use regulatory authority to keep people
out and thereby prevent their exposure
and if we can keep people out and
prevent their exposure then maybe we can
get away with not having to clean it up
i want to talk about malaria and this is
a very different kind of a problem and
this is probably the last case that i'll
be able to go through but i'll go
through it quickly
uh many in this country uh
do not think that that we face risks of
vector-borne disease
and if you look at our environmental
laws
they're predominantly designed to
control our exposure to synthetic
chemicals many of which were produced in
the 20th century
but if you place yourself in a low
income situation such as africa
moist
tropical africa
you find a very different matrix of risk
so what i'm suggesting here is we have
the luxury and high income nations to
worry about synthetic chemical
contamination and those risks
whereas many in the world face far more
serious risks
from biological agents
malaria is a disease that's been an
enormous killer
throughout human history
there are 300 to 500 million clinically
disabled people worldwide 40 of the
world's population is at risk
and 90 of the malaria incidence and
mortality uh mortality means death
uh that occurs in africa
it's treatable it's preventable
but they don't have the money to manage
it
about 1.5 million people are now
estimated by the world health
organization to die of this illness
every year uh and 80 of these are
children uh
and pregnant women pregnant women
because of their reduced immunity so
there's one death due to this illness in
the world every 30 seconds and
i wrote a book that included a chapter
on malaria several years ago and
the research i did for the book
led me to conclude that 250 million
people have died of malaria during the
20th century and if you add up all of
the people that died due to the direct
effects of warfare during the 20th
century
most military historians do not get
above about 150 million so this gives
you some sense of the scale of this kind
of a problem
the population at risk is predominantly
in these nations
there's about 200 million dollars
expended every year to try to control
malaria and the estimates of loss in
gross domestic product or gross economic
activity
of nations where this is endemic is
about 12 billion dollars
and this illness consumes about 40
percent of all money that is spent to
control public health or improve public
health in in africa
malaria is not the only serious
vector-borne disease
transmitted by mosquitoes
the the
uh illness known as dengue also is
endemic in in africa and parts of latin
america and uh one of the bad parts
about this story is that uh many of the
insects that carry these diseases
anopheles
mosquitoes carry malaria
80s egyptian carries uh dengue they're
becoming resistant to a variety of uh
the insecticides that are the least
costly insecticides and you may have
heard about the debate that went on in
the world health organization several
years ago
when the
persistent organic pollutant treaty was
being negotiated among nations to try to
phase out ddt worldwide and then african
nations uh
argued strenuously for continued access
to ddt
because it was persistent it was not
acutely toxic
and it was very effective at killing the
mosquitoes and they all they had stocks
of this of this compound
substitutes commonly cost four to eight
times more than ddt costs
so that nations that have almost no
money
are not likely to buy the synthetic
pyrethroids that we would spray say in
the united states for a vector-borne
disease problem
by the way that treaty was was passed uh
and i got a chance to sit on a panel
of of uh scientists that that
looked at the dangers of ddt compared to
the the dangers of of malaria
and we recommended to the the director
of the world health organization uh
brooklyn
that the african nations be exempt from
any sort of global ban on the use of ddt
despite its persistence
but because of the severe threat facing
these in these nations
some of the other key illnesses that you
find in the world include the the uh
encephalitis uh cases uh st louis
encephalitis uh in the orange west nile
virus that we're now experiencing in the
united states and uh by the way west
nile encephalitis was was found
only as as uh recently as year 2000 and
uh by
year 2004 uh look at these patterns of
incidents it was found in new york in
this area uh and now look at these
patterns of of incidents uh 2 900 people
reported cases and about 300 people per
year are now dying of west nile
encephalitis so this is uh this is one
of a group of emerging infectious
diseases uh that that uh had the
capacity to you know jump from uh one
area of the world to another area of the
world and they create some serious
management problems in our country we
will deal with this in a very different
way than the african nations because we
have a whole suite of chemicals that we
could use that are less persistent than
deep ddt uh that are less
toxic to wildlife
but they are more expensive
so what i'm suggesting here is that you
need to worry about the capacity the
institutional capacity to manage risk
and the the disparity in that capacity
among many many different nations
lyme disease is another example of a
vector-borne disease
a neurodegenerative disease that also
has arthritic symptoms and you should
know that we are kind of at uh we're
ground zero here uh this disease was was
uh first discovered by uh dr stern here
at yale and in the late 1970s
and you see also a pattern of spread
mostly to the the upper midwest
but with a special concentration here in
the in the east
here's a connecticut map showing the
reported cases
in 2004
and it uh this represents a serious
illness and there's a a rise in a
decline depending upon climatic
conditions from year to year this year
is a very it's a very bad year for these
deer ticks
so my recommendation is to to
check yourself check your kids for ticks
when you go out into the woods
many of these illnesses are transmitted
by mosquitoes
they they
include
parasites malaria in this case
that is is uh taken from an infected the
blood of an infected individual
the parasite goes through a reproductive
stage in the mosquito stomach
it actually explodes through the stomach
wall and then is inserted down the
proboscis
as the mosquito bites the next person
and injects a little bit of an
anticoagulant to make that next
individual bleed
and when it injects that anticoagulant
that's when the parasites get in
adjusted to the to the next person and
that's how an epidemic can can move
ahead
now
based upon this concern for vector-borne
disease i want to talk just a little bit
about pesticides i had a chance to work
with a couple of national academy of
sciences committees on pesticides over
the past
couple of decades and i just want to
give you a sense of the scale of this
problem
there are some 70 000 different
chemicals that are registered in the
world
23 000 of these are registered in the
united states but these compounds are
intentionally designed to be toxic
substances
and they create
significant economic benefits for crop
protection for timber protection
there are
rodenticides to kill rodents there are
algaecides there are slimocides there
are insecticides there are fungicides
there are herbicides
these are all a class of biocides that
were specifically designed to injure
cells of one sort or in one species or
another and one of the key mistakes was
a presumption on the part of of the
designers
that they would be very specific that
they would have the capacity to
adversely affect only one species
or perhaps one species at one point in
its in its life cycle
but the history of science has
demonstrated something very different
which is non-specificity
so that we used to think that a lot of
compounds were safe that for human
exposure when as whereas
the current understanding is is very
different
i want to point to two discoveries at
the same time
one by ed log working in the food and
drug administration who first found ddt
and human milk in 1951 and another the
discovery of iodine 131 produced from
atomic weapons explosions
that the atomic energy commission
discovered
in 1951
these two histories are extremely
uh similar in that
you had
the government sponsoring the production
of ddt as well as
the the atomic weapons
and
the testing of those compounds uh was
quite narrow allowing their broad scale
introduction uh to the environment
by 1952 the atomic energy commission
recognized that
the radio nuclides were circling the
globe
they were
raining down and thunderstorms and
settling as dust
in different parts of the world the
grasslands in connecticut were being
contaminated by explosions that were
occurring in nevada other explosions off
of the california coastline
even the explosions the large explosions
in the marshall islands
where the uss kiln that i showed you was
was part of one of those tests uh so the
failure to recognize that these
compounds could go into global
circulation
uh move long distances and result in
patterns of contamination and then move
back up a food chain was a discovery uh
that we knew in 1951 but throughout the
past 50 years we've repeatedly uh
neglected that history we have uh we
have a
a
a learning disability as a society we're
not we're not learning from our past
mistakes
and also there was a pattern of secrecy
that uh basically prevented
many people from
the knowledge that uh
iodine 131 was building up in the milk
supply it was building up in human
tissues
it has the capacity to to injure your
thyroid gland
and
by 1955 every human on earth
was known to carry levels of both ddt as
well as iodine 131 in their body tissues
now
this has this has sparked a whole new
scientific approach to understanding
what's worth worrying about
because we now know we can look for
contaminants in human tissues
so that experts are now able to find up
to 500 different chemicals in human
tissues it may be the hair
it may the hair is a good medium to test
for a variety of metals
methyl mercury as an example it could be
could be uh bone
i've got a colleague herb needleman at
the university of pittsburgh who
basically broke the whole issue about
kids exposure to lead and developed a
series of subtle cognitive neurological
tests to figure out that kids exposed to
high levels of lead
had
more problems with cognition memory and
learning
and lower iqs he was a guy that
discovered that relationship between
lead and
neuro neuro development and he did that
by testing baby's teeth he went around
and collected baby's teeth from dentists
uh other compounds are detectable in the
blood other in the urine uh so 500
different uh compounds that are
potentially toxic are now discoverable
if you went and had every possible test
uh right now well that would cost you
about ten thousand dollars to do that uh
but uh the average person uh that has
been tested is carrying about
between 75 and maybe 125 of these
synthetic compounds in one tissue or or
another
we don't know what this means
with with the exception of exposure to
just a few of these of these chemicals
uh so it's it's leading to a kind of a
whole new way of thinking about uh what
the word contamination means uh how much
is okay and uh you know where you should
set allowable limits in in law
i'm going to scoot ahead here and just
stop so that uh
you can you can tell that i way overshot
here and on what i was going to tell you
i'll leave you uh with a couple of
thoughts here about the food supply this
group of pesticides is known to get into
the food supply and i've studied kids
diets as a way of trying to understand
whether or not
their specific dietary patterns could
cause them to be exposed to a mixture of
chemicals in in a way that was more
dangerous than others uh and it turns
out that they are uh this is uh i
developed this chart really as a as a
joke when i was playing with uh some 3d
software and then i realized that
it provided the seed for understanding
the variability in exposure to to
pesticides that make their way into into
the food supply uh so that this
represents the diet of 170 children
across their 50 most consumed foods here
on the bottom and what you see here is
uh kind of the the mountains of orange
juice and
wheat flour and apple juice among this
is one to two year olds
and some kind of foothills of sugar over
here and then you see the valleys of
broccoli and cabbage and cauliflower and
the foods that you know kids hate
but this gave me the idea that well you
know why not just be strategic and
concentrate
the search
on the foods that kids eat the most of
and then see what chemicals appear on
those foods and figure out what the the
risk is from that
and this this approach
was brought together with residue data
when you go to the grocery store and you
buy non-organic food you're buying food
that does have pesticide residues in it
uh here's an example where
spinach for for uh for one case uh or
soybeans rather for one case
90 or 80 percent of the the samples
tested by the the food and drug
administration were found to have
residues so there are these residues out
there often at fairly low levels
but some of these residues have
properties that could allow them to
concentrate as foods are translated from
their raw form like apples to apple
juice or soybeans to soybean oil
in the same way that the the
ddt or
iodine 131 could could move its way up
up the food chain
so here's a group of organophosphate
insecticides that the government is
allowed to exist
and use in the food supply
and it's this is a relative ranking of
their toxicity so
and demonstrated by this list of
chemicals here on the left-hand side so
trying to figure out where the chemicals
are most often present in which foods uh
and which foods kids eat the most of it
provides a it provides a way of trying
to
strategically direct government's
attention uh to the most consumed foods
uh the the chemicals that have the
highest degree of toxicity
and
also the the
foods where residues commonly appear
some some pesticides are used on crops
and they don't appear they have a rapid
degradation rate
but
getting the government to be strategic
about how it spends it scares time and
to focus on susceptible populations has
been a uh
i think a major challenge
what's worth worrying about with respect
to pesticides i worry a lot about indoor
exposures
i've worked on a number of different
indoor contamination and
illness cases and now know that that
when you spray pesticides indoors uh
you're going to be exposed to a level
far higher than you would to the same
pesticide that might be allowed to be
used in the food supply so your exposure
comes in all three routes by
inhalation and dermal uptake uh as as
well as ingestion
so if you want to uh you know protect
yourself think about reducing the
your importation of hazardous chemicals
such as pesticides into your indoor
environment
i'm going to scoot down here to
just a closing slide i was going to take
you through a diesel bus study that we
did that that
found that
school buses are extremely dirty
environments
and
i'll stop here with just a couple of key
lessons
one key lesson that i want to leave you
with is that there's variable
susceptibility in the population
this can vary by age or by pattern of
exposure or by gender or ethnicity or
your location do you live in close
proximity to a hazardous facility
it also
is important to think about what quality
of surveillance we have ongoing in other
words
how many foods are actually sampled by
the government to figure out if they are
contaminated it turns out remarkably few
13 000 samples per year in fda anybody
want to guess how many different pieces
of food are sold in the united states
every year
maybe 100 trillion
100 trillion 13 000 samples when you've
got 100 trillion different pieces of
food that might have
some some residue in it i mean my
reaction to that is somebody that
worries a lot about sampling design is
why bother uh it's not giving you any
assurance that the food supply is safe
uh secrecy ownership of information is
critical here
uh the the
national environmental policy act uh the
administrative procedures act uh several
other statutes that i talked about
earlier uh they're very important
statutes because they allow you to ask
the government information
so
you have a greater right to know than
you used to have in the 1970s and 1980s
but the government also is not
monitoring a level that you would feel
secure about
so you have the right to ask them the
question but they're likely to come back
to you and say we didn't test we don't
know
ethical standards for decision making
you know the the va case and the
massachusetts case
cases tell me that
you know the value of precaution is high
we could save a lot of money by being
more precautionary in the way that we
manage our environment the way we manage
chemical release
our technology dispersion and most
products are now distributed globally
so that we have the problem not only of
managing our our environment
and toxic substances within our national
boundaries but also this trans boundary
flow of goods and services uh is
distributing risks that
unless you have a good surveillance
system set up good testing at the
borders you're not going to find
i'm going to jump down here
to to my own conclusion as well that
epa's website if you go to epa's website
they will claim that the environment is
much cleaner than it was
when
they they were begun in 1970 and i would
argue
any conclusion about whether or not
we're safer today than we were
when
these laws
were originally passed
depends very much upon what you choose
to measure
so that
don't be lured into a false sense of
security
so i'm going to stop there and just
entertain any questions that you have
yes
yeah the farm-raised issue i think is uh
it's very interesting and there are a
bunch of problems that are are
emerging with respect to to uh
fisheries cultivation
and they have to do with bacteria they
have to do with chemical contamination
uh they have to do with uh the potential
for buildup of contaminants in feed
that's fed to the fish
and also salmon i mean most
farm-raised salmon
is is colored
so that the
grocery stores can actually choose which
color salmon they want there's a color
fan that goes from kind of a very dark
pink to a very light pink
so they want their salmon to look like
wild salmon which is naturally pink
so that and
marketing surveys have demonstrated what
people like
so that
they don't like to buy gray salmon which
is the way that farm-raised salmon turn
out unless you feed them this artificial
flavor or artificial color excuse me
i think that
salmon tends not to absorb the
contaminants that i described
to the level of swordfish and
some of the other large predators
uh right wild salmon
but there are some contaminants but on a
if you were to to rank the uh the the
relative contamination of different
species uh they'd be closer to the
bottom
yes can you come in on the purity of
commercial
water
the safe drinking water act applies to
bottled water
um but it applies only to bottled water
that's transported across state
boundaries
uh so that if you wanted to set up your
own marketing scheme here in connecticut
you could go and get some bottles and
fill it up fill them up with a hose in
the garage and probably make some
serious money
yellow started to sell its own bottled
water as an example there's yale water
so that
the safe drinking water act requirements
are
applicable to a company like poland
spring i think that's what you have uh
to avion and what that means is that
that
those 93 contaminants that are on the
safe drinking water maximum contaminant
level list are are looked for during
their sampling efforts
the sampling
efforts are not always trusted by
companies like pollen spring so they
will go through their own filtration
process
and some companies take the minerals out
through filtration and treatment and
then they actually add some minerals
back in
to adjust the taste
so there
is a lot of variability there there was
a good study by the natural resources
defense council uh that you can find on
their website that compared brands of
bottled water uh and which ones uh had
higher contaminants than than others
uh yes i mean in some cases it depends
upon the plastic
and the softer plastics uh are more
likely to leach
and it's kind of impossible for you to
know what chemicals are leaching into
what kinds of foods because there could
be variability depending upon acidity
or other
the other
chemicals in the food and i think that
i try to avoid plastic uh as a as a
container for food it's a it's a really
hard thing to do these days as you know
even cans are cans and milk cartons are
lined with plastic
but if you if you can use glass as a
container i think that that's safer
plasticizing agents
such as bisphenol a have been found in
human tissues i have a slide of that
that i could have showed to you
so that uh the softer the chemical uh i
saw softer the plastic they think that
the higher the chance that it would
migrate uh
in my family we do not microwave things
in plastic
because that has been shown in some
cases to increase the rate of migration
uh to the food
other questions
but this is going yes be a tough tough
question
since they have the most to lose
hopefully they have the longest
lifespans and we want to keep them
having a long lifespan
what is the one thing you think these
young people could possibly do at their
that's a tough question
the one thing they could do what could
you do what was the one thing you could
do to uh
to best protect themselves or best
change things
well there's a lot uh
there's a lot that you can learn
uh
by
going on the internet if you wanted to
know what the most dangerous air
contaminants were the most dangerous
drinking water contaminants there's also
a lot of good advice out there about how
to reduce your exposure to air
pollutants food contaminants drinking
water contaminants
my wife and i wrote a brochure about
that how to reduce your your uh your
exposure to a variety of different uh
environmental health risks and you know
part part of the problem here is
uh there are many different kinds of
contaminants
and
at the root
of the problem is an absence of basic
literacy
uh on the part of the public and an
absence of
ecological thinking
part of the problem of environmental
management to reduce chemical
exposures is that these chemicals are
commonly not detectable by human senses
so that you need to therefore look for
proxy indicators where might you expect
to find them well i mean people people
do the darndest things i mean people
with shallow wells and sands and gravel
will go out and they'll spray pesticides
on their lawns
uh not thinking that uh gee you know it
might move from the surface down into
the drinking water
so that's in from my mind that's an
absence of ecological thinking
it's also a statement about how the
importance of green lawns uh has
dominated how people manage their
property
yes
should be tested for i mean we have our
water tested at a
lab in new haven to do a standard like
household water test but is there like a
specific list for
connecticut you know we really should be
checking business to see if it matches
up with the list
well you should definitely test for lead
i mean led is the the primary
concern
if you if you lived in an agricultural
area or if your house is built in a
former agricultural area as many houses
in connecticut were it would make sense
to test for pesticides if you live in
the vicinity of
any sort of a fuel supply such as a gas
station or
say any sort of a corporation that is
likely to be storing fuel on its site
then i would test for
chemicals commonly found in fuels
so you know benzene and
other uh
chlorinated compounds
uh but
if you went to most good laboratories in
connecticut and you also thought you
know ecologically about where you live
in relationship to other land uses and
you thought historically about patterns
of land use in your area that would give
you and would give the lab i think a
pretty good indication of the chemicals
to look for
why don't we uh wrap this up so that we
can talk to the speaker personally but
let's thank the speaker thank you very
much